[Music]
Microsoft Excel is the symbol yet a
modern scaler divided Excel
actually
the simple perspective software as now
part of most business across use of the
effect and strength what is fat suffer
from the advanced Excel section but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a technique in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trend
simply
pages of Ms Excel has its flexibilities
this
speed
Allah loves you
this is
to define the stock influence then
manage is that even if you use a
conflict the user needs and gained
Better Math external cheats as a period
and the data collected can be cleansed
modified and prepared using Advanced
Excel features
data can be run formulas and necessary
inside Sophia can be extracted not just
this this can also visualize the data of
King Excel one of the most powerful
businesses
in capitalism
tools
basically
support from Excel
allow users to cast
customize and generate into business
reports and dashboard XXL is popular for
that to say project status reports and
invoice reports Microsoft Excel is also
very popular amongst professionals from
data science background as it allows
them to easily work with statistical
formulas and graphing the finance
department makes use of Ms Excel for
payroll expenses tax calculations leave
reports timesheets and employee
performance analysis another important
use of Ms Excel for any industry is
forecasting this helps organizations in
Revenue projections cost projections and
manage their supply chain effectively
now let us go through the salaries of
data oriented jobs that require Ms Excel
the average salaries of data oriented
jobs with excellent requirements is
anywhere between 5 lakhs per annum to 10
lakhs per annum based on experience and
job roles and responsibilities having
the introduction and applications of
excel test cost now we will go through
the agenda for today's session we will
start off by discussing Excel basic
knowledge where we will go through the
fundamentals of excel followed by that
we will start with learning how to log
or protect cells in Excel followed by
that we will learn the print page setup
in Excel next we have goal seeking Excel
charts in Excel and then we will go
through data validation in Excel
followed by that we will go through the
lookup functions so there are basically
three types of lookup functions which
are vlookup Edge lookup and X lookup
followed by that we will learn slicers
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel budget template then we
will understand what exactly is Mis
report in Excel then we will dive into
Excel macros and visual basics for
beginners then we will learn regression
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel power query then the
perfect tables in Excel and find only to
make things interesting we will go
through the most frequently Asked Excel
based interview questions and answers so
I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with the
advanced Excel tutorial
what has Microsoft Excel so Microsoft
Excel is a software product designed and
developed by Microsoft is storing data
in an organized way that is rows and
columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
foreign followed by that Microsoft Excel
is also used to extract the insights
from the data and represent it in the
form of visually appealing graphs and
charts now we have a basic understanding
or an overview of what a Microsoft Excel
software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with Microsoft Excel so basically when
you install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
when a product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so we get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page so
this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel the type of square we
will see this in a better way so one